foreign
to remember this one
it's a Nokia 3310
once recognized as the greatest phone
ever produced
I guess most of you in this room owned
one didn't you please raise your hand if
you own the 3310
wow so almost 100 market share here
so you'll remember that it never ran out
of battery
you could play snake on it
it was world famous for being the
indestructible phone
so in the mobile industry the saying
used to go that if someone drops an
iPhone the screen breaks if someone
drops a Nokia 3310 the floor breaks it
was unbelievable solid
the 3310 embodied exactly what Nokia
stood for as a brand resilience quality
and innovation
it was products like this one that
turned Nokia into one of the most
successful companies on the planet
but as you will also remember there is
another and a more tragic side to this
story
because today the 3310 rest in peace at
the gadgets graveyard
become a symbol of the collapse of Nokia
a company that went from 50 Global
markets here to three percent in less
than five years
and it made me think that while we talk
a lot about how an organization achieves
success
maybe we don't talk enough about the
psychological challenges that often
follows success
because if you think about it almost
every industry has its own Nokia story
companies that once dominated their
industry but then somehow completely
lost the Mojo
they all leave us with that million
dollar question why do successful
companies actually fail
and what could they have done
to stay ahead of the pack
so I'm going to try and answer that
question today not by using additional
management thinking but by using an idea
from football analytics which I believe
explains why many successful companies
so often hesitate to change until it's
too late
before I start I need to ask a very
important question
do we have any Newcastle United
supporters in the room
yeah there's a couple of there so guys
I'm just gonna warn you the next 10
minutes will be painful
okay I know the last 25 years have been
painful but okay don't take this
personal
this is the stadium of Newcastle United
St James's Park every other week 50 000
Die Hard supporters blocked to the
stadium to watch the team play
and instinctively Newcastle United has
all the building blocks to become a
really successful football clubs they
got a billionaire businessman owner they
got a fan base most other clubs would
die for
but despite all that Newcastle is also
known as the team that never really
fulfilled its potential
but then a little bit more than five
years ago in 2012.
Fortune seems to change for Newcastle
because they sensationally finished
fifth in the English Premier League the
strongest league in the world
that was an amazing achievement all the
experts predicted Newcastle to be
battling avoid relegation now they were
fifth
inside Newcastle the excitement we're
bubbling to the management team was
convinced this is the start of a new era
in the football club's history
so they decided to reward the head coach
and his old coaching the historic long
unbreakable ADR contract and they really
tried to do everything they could to
keep the squad together for The
Following season because that's how
successful organizations are supposed to
think right The Following season
this happened
Newcastle almost relegated they finished
16th and no one had a clue what was
going on
because they had the same players
they had the same coaching staff They
even played in the same stadiums I mean
nothing's changed How could a largely
unchanged team go from 5th to 16th in
less than 12 months
I'm going to try and answer that
question but first i'm gonna give you a
little bit of background
because in football there's a good old
expression it's frequently used by
coaches players commentators experts it
goes like this
the league table never lies
it kind of assumes that once the last
game of a season is played justice
prevails the teams that finish top of
the table is the best performing team
and it seems that relegate are the worst
performing teams at the end of the day
everyone gets what they deserve
it's not that simple actually and let me
explain you why
please meet Matthew Benham he's a
gambler
he convinced me the brightest guys in
football they don't work for the
football clubs they work in the gambling
industry and I'm not talking about the
amateur Gambler the guy that is placing
a bit every Saturday morning to trigger
trigger his weekly Rush of adrenaline
I'm talking about the pros the guys that
are using sophisticated mathematical
models to place the bets that's the
brightest guys and Matthew is one of
them he's an Oxford graduate in physics
that decided to set up his own bidding
Syndicate in North London basically an
office full of PhD statisticians
calculating the probabilities for the
outcome of football games
that has made him a rich man so rich
he decided to buy the football club he
supported since he was a teenager
Brentford in West London and that's
where I met him five years ago at Jersey
Road the training ground of Brentford
at the time we met Brentford was third
in League one which is the third tier of
English football there was only five
games remaining of the season and
Brentford was pushing for a promotion
so I said to Matthew
what do you think are you going to
promote this season what what does your
gut feel say
and I didn't he gave me an answer I
didn't quite expect
it was not an answer full of excitement
the guy just looked at me and then he
said very dry well at the moment there's
a 42 chance we'll promote
that comment made me realize that I met
someone who fought completely different
about the game than I ever met before
over the next couple months Matthew and
I started to meet regularly to exchange
ideas about how you could run a football
club differently in particular how would
it be possible to break the correlation
between spending and results that seems
to exist is it possible to not outspend
but out think the competition by using
the weapons of a gambler data and
Analytics
one day we had lunch at a restaurant
together
in SoHo in London and Matthew said to me
he'd been looking to buy another
football club and I immediately
responded why don't you take a look at
the club I supporter when I was a
teenager if Saint michulan based in the
Western Rural Denmark in the middle of
nowhere Michigan was almost broke at the
time so it was a perfect place to think
radical ideas
a week later we flew to Denmark and we
had a look at the club eventually he
decided to buy the club he made me the
chairman of the club and we run the club
together for the past four years in the
first season we won the first
championship in the club's history and a
year later we became a world famous
because we beat the mighty Manchester
United in the Europa League
unfortunately in the UK that's more
perceived as these the the absolute
embarrassment of Manchester United than
the genius of Michelin but we will live
with that
suddenly Media newspapers TV stations
from all the world was flying to Western
Denmark to learn more about this little
Club no one can pronounce the name of
which is run by an English Gambler using
data and analytics to find a competitive
ads
so here's the thing if you want to
understand
how a gambler thinks there's one concept
you must get is this
the league table always lies why is the
Gambler saying that because he
understands football is a very random
game it's a much more random game than
basketball for example why is that
because football is a low scoring sport
there's not a lot of goals in football
you know the average number of goals in
a football game is 2.8 the average
number of goals in a basketball game is
above 200. here's the principal
the fewer goals there is in a sport the
more impact random events have random
events like the ball getting deflected
and Spins into the net or the referee
making a wrong call in the last minute
of the game
ultimately this means that's the best
team wins less often in football a low
scoring sport than in a high scoring
sport like basketball and that's why the
league table lies it lies more after 10
games than after 20 games but even 38
games that is a full season 38 games is
a very small sample size
you know it's not enough to strip out
the randomness from the equation
so our Gambler is in the business of
making predictions and backing those
predictions with his bets and when he
decides to back a team and place a bets
he doesn't look at where that team is in
the league table he looks at underlying
performance indicators that have more
predictive value tells him more about
whether team is likely to go in the
future than his current league jail
position
so let's go back to newcastle's Glory
season when they finish Fifth and
revisit that through the lens of a
gambler because whereas experts in the
game were overly impressed by Newcastle
performance the gamblers were very
skeptical their analysis showed that
this was a fragile bubble that could
burst anytime here's why one of the
statistics a gambler trust a lot is the
statistic called goal difference is the
difference between the number of goals
at team scores versus the number of
goals the opponent scores is a very
reliable indicator for team strength
so let's look at that
Newcastle finished fifths with a total
shot difference of plus five
a long way behind the four top teams and
if you look at that column is by far the
lowest number this indicates what a game
block holds an extremely effective goal
distribution all goes in football are
important not all goals are equally
important so here's an example let's say
Newcastle scores two goals over two
games and the opponent scores six goals
Newcastle will be better off winning one
nil in this first game losing 6-1 in the
second rather than losing twice free one
same goal difference but different
number of points so if a team is able to
produce can see the number of goals
throughout the season how effective with
those scores fall the goal distribution
there's a big degree of Randomness to
that and if you break down Newcastle 65
points this season you will see that it
was driven by a very effective gold
distribution eight wins with one goal
and three major losses with more than
three goals it's very unlikely
statistically to be able to repeat 65
points with a plus five goal difference
another statistic a gambler trust is
something called shot differential the
difference between the number of shots a
team produces versus the number of shots
the opponent produces
it's statistically very well documented
in football that the best team over time
produce more than the worst teams so
let's have a look at that
and as you can see Newcastle finished
fifth with a total shot differential of
minus 1.4
clearly they don't belong in this
company
this indicates
unsustainable High conversion rate when
you have a positive goal difference
driven by a negative shot differential
it indicates
unsustainable High conversion rates how
many of those shots were converted to
goals a Newcastle had especially one
player this season who stood out she
said the top score
a key component of their success he
converted 33 of his shots ladies and
gentlemen that's a freaky number here's
how I would put it
newcastle's fifth place
is the equivalent of a public traded
company having a very high share price
and a very low customer satisfaction at
the same time
you can have that for one year but you
can't maintain that over time here's a
visualization of how a gambler perceived
the situation
the black line shows the number of
points Newcastle achieved throughout
those two seasons when they were Fifth
and when they were 16. the red line is
the underlying performance what a
gambler calls expected points
so as you can see Newcastle got a lot
more points in the first season when the
Finn is fifth then the underlying
performance Justified
actually Newcastle performed almost the
same way in those two seasons
they just got less lucky
and this reframes the original question
because why did Newcastle management
team not see this downside coming
why did they decide to reward the head
coach with a historic long unbreakable
contract when the results were clearly
unsustainable
I believe that Newcastle was blinded by
one of the most common management
delusions what psychologists call
outcome bias the assumption that good
results are always the consequence of
good decisions and Superior performance
or let's put it in another way success
turns lock into genius
and this is where the message becomes
about much more than just football
analytics right
because when an organization fails it
comes very natural for us to dig for
reasons to ask the tough questions why
did we fail how can we do things better
but when we are successful we don't ask
those questions we tend to just cruise
on blinded by outcome buyers we expect
results to continue automatically we
don't dig into them and ask what was
actually the underlying reasons for the
success was it because of the oil price
was because of good leadership or
because of exceptional market conditions
how many companies do you think confuse
good leadership with good market
conditions here's the thing successful
organizations should think more like a
good gambler
because a good Gambler has trained his
brain to resist the human tendency to
assume that good outcomes always mean
that someone acted brilliantly a good
Gambler treats success with the same
skepticism as he treats failure and this
is what successful organizations should
do too if they want to stay relevant ask
themselves the questions of a gambler
why were we actually successful how do
we separate luck from skill
is it possible that our league table
sometimes lies you thank you very much
[Applause]